happy with the draw so he doesn't take
any risks he just offers a trade of
light-squared bishops if those
light-squared bishops disappear white
does remove a bit of the risk involved
and he does edge closer to a safe
position yeah
and uh there we can see the bishop moves
attacking the queen and the queen
promptly moves to the b4 square just uh
cutting off the king's path to
safety so the position has now repeated
itself this is the second time we've
seen this position
duda has a big decision to make a draw
is the same as a loss though so he
should play on okay
now this is the second time we've seen
this position and duder just allows the
draw he doesn't even try to keep the
game going magnus carlsen wins today's
match it's three points for magnus
carlsen he is the winner of the first
match against young christophe duda here
in the tour finals uh a short day for
magnus carlsen after only a few hours of
play it's over what do you think went
through young chris of judah's mind
there